[Music]  it's finally December and this  Kardashian ketchup is getting us into  the holiday spirit Kylie Jenner rocked a  red mini dress while in Miami with her  longtime love Tyga and when she got back  to the hotel room she got a little racy  and sparkly fishnet eyes she twists it  around in her sheets sister Kourtney  Kardashian is getting festive with this  throwback and is showing off her  gingerbread house from mom Kris Jenner  ding ding ding did I went on display  courtney Mason Penelope Raines names but  hmm no Scott Disick that baby Chris sent  a similar gingerbread house to Rob and  blac Chyna and Rob Canyon dreams  [Music]